The Souls of the children that Aton had
killed lingered in the mascot suits and
instead of moving on to the afterlife
they stayed on Earth and eventually
learned how to control the same
animatronics that their bodies had been
stuffed into when Gabriel was alive he
was a mild-mannered polite child but
after his murder he became vengeful and
enraged once he learned how to control
the Fazbear animatronic Gabriel saw this
newfound power as an Avenue to get
revenge on the man that killed him and
hopefully then move on from the mortal
world Jeremy Susie Fritz and Cassidy
shared a similar goal with their ghosts
inhabiting the other animal animatronics
Bonnie Chica foxy and golden Freddy
while it's not mentioned exactly what
year fredbear's Family Diner was shut
down it seems likely that it happened
shortly after the murder